[Music]
[Music]
turn around
go on
I'm gonna die
[Music]
there's man whoa look at that new guy
who's that that's my cue I gotta go
butterfly with Captain American I stole
his shield up throw it at him he's big
with swords amazing thing that's ever
happened to mrs. Oakes like a ruse and I
just sort of flipped in hey just a
second coming
hey Nathan Walsall the rich and the
powerful I don't care about us
it's pick up after with each their table
scraps these alien masters are tough you
gotta use the stuff they use the world's
change time we change two ways Linux
retreat next mission will call you keep
it a little more med touring if you're
real last six into you that's not a hug
and just grab the door for you oh all
right kid
good luck out there someone is
collecting stuff from Avengers battles
I'm building these crazy weapons this is
my chance to prove myself
what if somebody had died to a different
story right cuz that's on you I wanted
you to be better eight years without any
trouble from those bozos up in stark
tower and it's all bastard red tights
shows about he thinks he can tear down
everything I've built a Plane full of
brand-new Avengers weaponry to load up
we're going to put them out of business
we're gonna take everything they've got
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]
you